[Applause]
relief for the family of ahmad arbury
hand in hand they walked down the
courtroom steps after his killers were
given life in prison i knew that today
would come
when
when it would come
i didn't know but i know today would
finally come amen
on the 23rd of february 2020 ahmad
arbury a black american had gone out for
a run in a predominantly white
neighborhood in the u.s state of georgia
and never came home
instead he was targeted by these three
men who have now been sentenced for his
murder
a judge said that mr aubry was pursued
in pickup trucks for five minutes before
being cornered and shot by father and
son greg and travis mcmichael and their
neighbor william bryan who claimed they
were attempting a citizen's arrest on a
suspected burglar
he was killed
because individuals here in this
courtroom
took the law into their own hands
but the case has again raised questions
about racial justice in the southern
united states
mr aubry's family lawyers described the
incident as a modern-day lynching and in
response to the jury's verdict in
november president biden said we must
recommit ourselves to building a future
of unity and shared strength where no
one fears violence because of the colour
of their skin
the men waved their right to address the
court at the hearing but their lawyers
say they plan to appeal the convictions
katie barnfield sky news